[Musique]
les gens que vous voyez sur ces images
n'existe pas ils ont été créés de toutes
pièces par intelligence artificielle
pourtant ils ont l'air plus vrai que
nature
mais un détail les trahis leurs mains
souvent il y a trop de doigts où il y a
des doigts qui sont soudés ensemble où
les ongles ne sont pas à la bonne place
ou le doigt n'est pas tourné
correctement sur la mer il faut savoir
que les mains sont particulièrement
difficiles à reproduire même pour
l'intelligence humaine
les mères de Saint peinture
c'est une domaine qui est très difficile
à travailler
moi-même dans ma pratique c'est quelque
chose que je mets beaucoup d'accent
ces nombreuses
la main est une des parties les plus
complexes de l'anatomie humaine elle est
composée de plusieurs segments qui
peuvent prendre des positions
différentes les uns par rapport aux
autres
complexité je pense aux doigts
qui choque il y a plusieurs doigts qui
chevauchent dessus l'autre je vais
regarder les espaces qui existent entre
les doigts pour mieux comprendre aussi
les articulations
le mouvement de la main
[Musique]
avant que les artistes ne maîtrisent
cette partie du corps ce n'est qu'à la
Renaissance que l'on a commencé à avoir
des mains réalistes
en termes de comprendre aussi le corps
humain les proportions je pense beaucoup
des artistes comme des Vinci qui a eu
accès à des cars ou ce qui faisait des
analyses de comprendre comment certains
partis du corps qui fonctionne mais
contrairement à nous l'intelligence
artificielle n'a aucune idée de ce qui
est réellement humain
donc avant de pouvoir générer ses
propres images le logiciel en magazine
d'abord des millions d'images existantes
qui proviennent d'un peu partout sur le
web
celle-ci sont accompagnées de mots clés
qui permettent de savoir ce qui s'y
trouve
à partir de cela l'algorithme crie de
nouvelles images selon les critères de
l'utilisateur c'est qu'il va prendre
tous les éléments qui sont
correspondants aux mots qu'on a donné
faire un amalgame avec ça pour commencer
à recréer certaines parties et à partir
de là il va faire une reconnaissance
est-ce qu'il y a des choses similaires
dans cette construction d'image par
rapport à d'autres images que je possède
à l'intérieur et il fera des corrections
malgré tout le résultat final n'est pas
toujours correct
c'est que dans les banques d'image les
mains peuvent avoir une infinité de
position finalement dans toutes ces
images qu'on a ramassées sur le net les
mains occupent une petite partie de
l'image simplement et donc l'information
est plus ou moins cachée au système pour
l'apprentissage
en réunissant ces images disparaître le
résultat semble parfois sorti tout droit
d'un cauchemar et même quand il réussit
à faire une main avec cinq doigts il
nous met des chiffres pour nous montrer
qu'il a bien compris
mais l'intelligence artificielle est en
constante évolution et qui sait où elle
sera rendue dans quelques mois il y a eu
une progression fabuleuse au niveau de
la profondeur des textures au niveau de
la qualité des rendus et des
géométriques si on continue avec cette
croissance là dans trois quatre mois
d'ici on en reparlera plus de ce
problème là
[Musique]